Transfer procedures OK Uniforms OK High speed OK
Cockpit regulations
OK I
've applied for aerials
5 minutes before arrival
That's the school
Mother finally came
Activity food
Please check the rescuers' situation
[music] Leave the
rescue to me
Mobile suit pilot Are you ready to go outside?
Music]
I won't help you now
[Music] Don't
disturb me
[Music] It's
okay I almost escaped, but it's all
ruined because of you.
I'm a
mechanic or a 2nd year 2nd or Nanaura If you do
n't know anything, ask me It's my
first time here, so I
came from Mercury for the first time, but I really lived there.  I'm
wearing that old-looking hair band because my mom said so I wo
n't stop
[music] I've
heard about the situation, so I'll join the class as soon as I
can.  The
woman who
got in the way at that time, what's so stupid
?
This carnival general will be the witness
[music] I want to
get involved
[music] Did you
see the
duel?
This guy laughed at me He said he was the man who ran away from his bride.
It's not because he's
not, he's
going to duel himself as he pleases At this school, students will duel each other for something important Money,
rights,
apology,
marriagepartner That's
why you're getting married?
Defense Systems
That concludes
our Benefit Group's top performers this season.
However, we don't need a group that continues to record losses and run a deficit.
If you do, our company will go bankrupt,
yes.
What are you
going to do with me?  I'll
bite into it as it is
Delicious
Tomatoes aren't all delicious That's the kind of
tomato that my mother made, isn't
it?
That's right,
your mother is still alive. Lend me your
student notebook.  I
came up with a good idea
You're
going to live on our jet app from
now on I'm done with the fuss about escaping Because I
don't approve It's a rule your father decided If your parents
decide, you'll definitely do what your dad says  [
MUSIC]
What are
you doing?
Didn't you
go out of control from your mother?  It's the
current holder The
school's number one pilot who was chosen in a duel
Even so, bad things are bad
Hurry up
Here, what will open last time will be decided in a duel
Or will you marry me
?
Stop it, it's nothing to do with you It's
funny If you lose, you'll be expelled from school
[Music]
Move to Career Gate 2 Preliminary package
installed [
Music]
Even transfer students have a path to the tactical test area
Soccer without objects is also allowed
Really  Are you sure? I
have to do it before the duel to be confirmed as a fiancé becomes a blank sheet.Please detonate
10 minutes after I'm seconded.The
long
relationship is over today.
[Music]
Isn't that flashy? Do
n't you see the error? I'm
not
interested.  Both
break the blade antenna of the suit and claim victory
[music]
What's the matter?
Do you accept the change?
[Music]
Winning or losing is not determined solely by the performance of the mobile suit, it is not
determined solely by the skill of the operator
[Music] Fix
release Can an
amateur handle a mobile suit?  Do
n't decide on a business strategist princess can't win
Hey
[music]
you're just a trophy
[music] You're
over the speed limit, slow down  It
's mine It's nothing to
do with you What is
this? We'll
always be
together as a family
If it's a responsibility, I'll win and fulfill it Me and Aerial won't
lose to
someone like that
Reproduce the opponent
[music] The
ignorance of the country people  I'll fix it
My mother said If you
run away, you'll get two if you move forward If you run away, you
won't lose, but you'll get it But if you move forward, you'll
win Even if you don't win, you'll get it
Experience points and
pride  Even if you
kill President Telling now, your
fiancée is Guell-sama.  No,
who's the opponent?
Grasley?
[Music] You've
won I
think so Thretta Mercury [Music] This costume is proof of the winner of the duel, Holder, and it's also proof of my fiancée.
[Music]
Nice to meet you Bridegroom
Thinking of the stars floating in the distance, I fall
asleep The future you choose No matter
where the road leads, we'll live together
forever
[Music]  ]
Memories of the past
On this planet that brought me here You continued to wish
If you were able to jump into the glittering scenery in the distance In a
lonely world
Pray and make a wish
Draw a dream and
see the future
You choose to move forward rather than run away  If that's the case, it's
not a road that someone drew,
but a story that we create Because we'll
never leave you alone Born on this planet,
continuing this world, so that you can love everything I give you
full
blessings
[Music]
Next move  Warrior Gundam
Witch of Mercury Cursed Mobile Suit